could amanda tapping be doing an awful
lot more than just appearing in the new
stargate series
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so
we know if amazon decided to go with
brad wright's project for the new
stargate series that he has already
tapped up amanda tapping no pun intended
and daniel shanks to appear in it and
also maybe would behind the camera as
directors
but
according to my sources mgm actually
they're thinking about trying to involve
her an awful lot more than that and
maybe trying to get on board as an
executive producer
now this is something amanda tapping has
actually done a few times before she was
executive producer on sanctuary the
project that she left stargate for in
the first place she also directed
several episodes of her series as well
as appearing in it she also executive
produced and starred in the movie space
milkshake a movie that's so bad it's
kind of brilliant
as well as being an executive producer
on her current project motherland for
salem now this is a project that
has just completed its second season and
is about to go into its third season
but it's already actually been announced
by freeform that this third season will
be its final season now this is a show i
can't really tell you an awful lot about
sensibly because i've never actually
seen it but i do know that it's um
executive producers will ferrell it's
about three witches that were being
weaponized by the us military now like i
say i've not seen it but i know it has
been well received by viewers and a lot
of people are actually very disappointed
that the third series will be the final
one
my point here though is
once that is complete it does free up
amanda tapping to take on a role in a
big new project the production of
motherland for salem will be completed
roughly in the summer
about the same time that i believe a big
stargate project will be green lit
could amanda tapping be brought into
that in a way to appease fans as i've
said in a previous video talking about
how stargate is being planned for and
what amazon's priorities are
a big part of that is they want to use
stargate and other projects as a way to
improve their public persona they're
kind of seen as the bad guys at the
moment pushing their way in and bullying
mgm
they're just the big money people that
don't really care about the projects
that they work on
they want to use projects like stargate
to change that persona and to try to
improve their public image
now one way of getting fans on side
do a new project but bring the old
actors back
we might see daniel jackson brad wright
has already said we're going to see
general carter
brad wright has already talked to
michael shanks and amanda tapping about
directing episodes
it's a really easy way for amazon to get
fans the original fans of stargate
excited about this new project
and bringing amanda tapping on as an
executive producer something that she's
done several times before would again be
a really easy way to get fans excited
we know she can work with brad wright
and we know she can work with people
like michael shanks she also loves the
project she loves the series and i don't
think that
we have to really worry about a new
stargaze series if brad wright could get
a team around him that involves people
like amanda tapping
amanda tapping is a very experienced tv
director she's done several projects a
lot of projects with the cw
she's done a lot of projects of tv
series i actually can't stand like
batwoman but she's also done a lot of
other projects things like travelers
which i did enjoy and i actually think
this is a no-brainer for amazon if they
can get amanda tapping to come back if
i think she will want to do more than
just appear as general carter i think
she will want to be involved in
directing and potentially as an
executive producer role
i don't see any reason why amazon would
refuse that because it's very clear that
it would appease fans and that is a big
motivation for amazon executives
i am absolutely certain that march april
may sort of time the amazon sale is
going to be going through and mgm will
become part of the amazon family
when that happens i think within only
weeks or maybe a few months we will hear
about a stargate reboot
i think a quick and easy way to get fans
on board
bring amanda tapping in
so what do you think do you want to see
amanda tapping directing episodes do you
want to see her as an executive producer
or would you much rather see it on the
screen as general samantha carter
or actually are you not bothered do you
not really care which actually you just
rather they just got on with it and
really maybe bring in some new blood
some new talent to reignite this project
and to reignite stargate in a new
interesting way
either way leave a comment and tell me
exactly what you think so if you are new
to the channel please like subscribe hit
that bell notification share the video
wherever the hell you like
you can also join the channel and help
me by giving me a small contribution
every month to create more projects and
become a sidetracker supporting the
channel
you can also join us on facebook the
link is in the description as always
guys please stay safe i'll see you soon
you